i said something about chrissy teigen
what'd you say oh yeah
wait wait anyway all right so
right yeah yeah she out of here bro well
she obviously it's funny
when i had a gripe then they were like
oh the way you said it [ __ ] you you know
everybody they got me out of here yeah
no but but really so chrissy teague in
this whole bullying thing she's always
done it
i remember like again this is when like
six nights just when it's i remember she
had tweeted some
something i was like a pitcher like made
a picture of me in six nine like
cuddling and she made like almost it was
super like uh um homosexual reference to
it and i was like wait this is all
cool and and i never say anything about
it yeah and then she said something else
but it was like i think i was trending
at the day and she like retweeted me
like yo
what a [ __ ] weird like something like
that right yeah now she deleted all
those tweets i realized she's great
yeah but i told you copy save
you know i mean i'll save i always do it
right yeah yeah and one night
when her husband john legend's album
dropped
legends the [ __ ] so like what 13
000. john legend's album dropped oh
i thought he was pluralizing his last
name oh no his album
his album dropped and she's so outspoken
on social media
and and i was reading i do sales for
everybody in hip-hop and just music
period
i was like how the [ __ ] does he set like
13
000 when his wife is on twitter
starting up every conversation and hail
storm
every day why doesn't she use her
platform
to promote his [ __ ] album yeah now
granted
i didn't mention some colorful language
and i might have said the b word okay
but still it was meant in the context of
hey
check your chick in terms of her always
getting happy what did you call her you
call her bok choy
this is but
and by the way you know i did later
apologize for her [ __ ]
i had to i'm gonna be honest with you
why because
at first i wasn't going to him by the
way there's been times when now you
could call her a [ __ ] right like she
told a 17 year old girl to die
to kill herself well that's also the
thing with social media before people
knew she was a [ __ ]
that's the thing was like a [ __ ] you
could get away with saying the
craziest [ __ ] call her [ __ ] now no no
she she told a 17 year old girl to kill
herself
no what well here's the thing that's big
can you say [ __ ]
no no i have a lot of you can't say
[ __ ] well i wouldn't
one i'm gonna tell you why and we'll
tell you why i apologize
because and i've been i remember with
sizzle was like upset
like one time i described her on twitch
and then
she came in for an interview and she saw
that she's like because i know i should
look and i was like and i made a
description of how it sounded
yeah she was upset and complex told me
apologies i said no
the reason why i apologize for the the
um
you want to say it no i don't you don't
think she's [ __ ] i'm gonna be honest
the reason why is like
i worked with a female nedeska
and i remember her telling me she was
like yo listen
i know how supportive of me
you are and you know you know my plight
through this entertainment industry
and i'm gonna be honest when i watch
what you said granted i get that she
said things about you before
but it felt like you were belittling
women
and i had to apologize even though
i was trying to personalize it to her
but the mere thought that it was like i
was trying to um
just offend all women but you weren't
you're calling her specifically a [ __ ]
but if it's someone that's on your side
well
everybody loved her i know everybody
loved her calling her
that particular word was called
everybody was calling everyone that's
right because they were
yeah yeah yeah yeah and she's on she's
like oh you've done a lot for me i know
who you are
i'm just telling you it's still to me
with that knowledge sounded this way
yeah yeah just apologies she called you
a body boy bro
now she did
[Laughter]
because when i tried to explain it at
first everyone was like yo where are the
tweets like we don't even know where it
doesn't exist like you just seem
so i was caught in a vacuum where
they're like we didn't see when she
provoked you
yeah we only see you when you shout out
the club
like nobody saw what she spit spitting
your face outside the club yeah and now
you're like [ __ ] i'm going through
yeah
this whole [ __ ] gets shot up we only saw
that so and i was like you know i took
the l but i watch what she's going
through and i kind of feel bad for her
i feel bad for her because it's a lot
they're doing a lot you know like i
i think she she's been the person
that's leading the mom to try to get
people out of here before
and she never realizes that when that
happens to you
there's never a point of sympathy where
someone says i think she gets it
chill there's never a point of
redemption to be like yo yeah i think
she's sorry
there's never a point of of anything
where it's like yo
all right yo you know what let's give
her another chance those things never
happen with cancer culture
yeah and she's been on the opposite side
so i look at it and that's why i don't
like
i'm not happy about it because truth be
to the person i am and a priority person
all you guys are like you we will all
get canceled for a bunch of [ __ ]
and come back because cancer culture now
means like we ain't [ __ ] with you for
this week but it's probably next week
yeah probation sure next week if you
like do some funny [ __ ] or you go viral
we [ __ ] with you
my [ __ ] is like i don't know i don't
like people who pretend to be perfect
like she's
she's cancelling all these people and
knowing full well she told a 17 year old
killing themselves like that's crazy
like
you're acting as if you're perfect
you're criticizing people for their
worst moments
moments how could you blame her a lot of
the things the way
a lot of things they're accusing her of
wasn't just in the dark some of it was
someone through dms
yeah but she was kind of doing a lot of
this stuff on her timeline and people
were supporting it
that's why i hate about it it's kind of
like the rory and milamo type of [ __ ] i
was telling you about right
you gonna sit here and listen to this
[ __ ] and say all this [ __ ] yeah and
then now
you gonna jump off the bandwagon and get
mad at the [ __ ] for saying the same
[ __ ] that you were sitting with them
she was doing she never only did this in
private
she did this in public and private she
was rewarded
and nobody was like why y'all were on
the the christianity in bandwagon no one
said
hold up christy no you waller with this
no chill yeah no one did that by the way
one of the other people who claimed that
she said something about them
the dude at the time was being canceled
for being potentially racist
everybody all the time i was like get
that you know you know it's a mob it's
like
we don't care now when everyone's like
your level-headed emotional comedy
yeah whoa okay i know we've been killing
men but like
we didn't mean to actually tell him to
kill himself yeah you did that yeah yeah
yeah come on you're flip-flopping